[Musica]
[Applauso]
partita che california ecco la suoniamo
non c'entrava che però tratto se ci
pensate è una canzone degli eagles
molti di voi vedo che ci sono tantissimi
giovani e anche qualche diversamente
giovani quindi ve lo dovreste ricordare
chiude il testo con un qualcosa che è
molto simile all autismo perché dice
tradotto puoi fare il check out quando
vuoi ma in realtà da qua non uscirai mai
e dall'autismo io vi parlo di autismo
non si esce mai chi vi dice che c'è una
guarigione o d'altro non è una malattia
non c'è una guarigione
l'autismo è una condizione prima di
raccontarvi perché vi vorrei portare in
una casa di un caregiver che arriverà è
colui che si prende cura di in questo
caso di un ragazzo di una ragazza
autistica che quindi un genitore un papa
una madre un fratello una sorella o non
e quant'altro e vive in una casa una
casa fatta di quattro muri questi
quattro muri sono più o meno da
abbattere e vorrei guidarvi in questa
diciamo lotta a questi quattro muri
prima però concedetemelo 4 dati 4
informazioni sull'autismo giusto per
capire intanto l'autismo è una
condizione in cui ci sono dei deficit a
livello della comunicazione a livello
dell'immaginazione dell'interazione
sociale
diciamo interessi ristretti accompagnati
da stereotipi e comportamenti problemi e
l'autismo e molto democratico perché non
interessa il colore della pelle non gli
interessa dove vivi non gli interessa se
si è ricco povero l'autismo colpisce 1
su 100 una persona ogni 100 rientra
nello spettro autistico in qualunque
parte del mondo di qualunque razza è un
po maschilista ecco questo è l'unica
roba devo dirlo perché l'ottanta per
cento sempre in tutto il mondo qualunque
razza condizione sociale ed altro è a
carico vede il sesso maschile
i maschi e femmine solo un 20 per cento
quindi tante volte sentite parlare al
maschile ma non perché c'è una volontà
diciamo di discriminatoria quindi è
molto molto democratico e colpisce
l'ottanta per cento a cosa
a cosa è dovuto ci sono ormai sempre di
più diverse teorie che indicano la
componente genetica come responsabile
dell'autismo ma non è solo questa ci
sono anche delle questioni
multifattoriali come può essere
l'ambiente o da altro e come potrei
descriverlo come una bomba a mano una
bomba a mano l'autismo e la bomba ma la
spoletta che rimane lì lo bloccano lo fa
uscire oggi ci sono delle condizioni che
rimuovano questo a spoletta e fanno
esplodere l'autismo
i numeri sono aumentati in modo
esponenziale
ricordo uno ogni cento è un numero
estremamente devastante che sia poi la
componente genetica è anche stato
ritrovato in alcuni geni sembrerebbe che
tra i vari ricerche ci sono sette geni
implicati nella nel portare all'autismo
sette geni è una domanda a cui do io una
risposta alla faccia voi mamme hanno
risposto in modo inquietante nel passato
7 che cosa vi ricorda un giorno uno mi
ha detto i sette nani non è questo sette
sono come le note musicali
ora voi immaginate con 7 mo note
musicali quante melodie
potete comporre immaginate 7 gen i
compromessi
questi sette geni a quanti diciamo
tipologie di disturbi differenti si
possono tenere infatti si parla di
autismo perché pur avendo questi macro
mondi la comunicazione l'interazione
sociale che vi ho detto prima
hanno tutti diciamo delle
caratteristiche diverse pur essendo
rientrando in questi macro mondi
bene ora vi faccio entrare in questo
questo queste quattro mura che
ovviamente non le vedete e vele voglio
descrivere il primo muro che si affronta
è un muro subdolo e il muro della
consapevolezza è un muro che non vedete
infatti non lo vedete ma non lo vedi
neanche da fuori e il muro che quando tu
ricevi una diagnosi la diagnosi
normalmente avviene entro i due anni
circa verso i 14 mesi perché all'inizio
questi bambini queste bambine sono belli
sani parlano giocano non vedi differenza
con quelli che sono chiamati
tecnicamente normo tipici quindi normali
è un termine sbagliatissimo però
concedetemelo ma in realtà inizia a
cambiare qualcosa
iniziano ci sono tanti segnali ti
accorgi che c'è qualcosa che non va nel
tuo figlio
hai la diagnosi tuo figlio è autistico
la maggior parte delle persone non sa
neanche cosa vuol dire all'autismo non
lo conosce
oppure magari se lo conosce sa dei
luoghi comuni
ci sono dei film e quant'altro e rain
man non mi veniva anche fuori riapre
parzialmente hanno però poche conoscenze
è un momento delicatissimo tutti chiedi
perché quando ti nasce un figlio ti
inizia a chiedere o mio figlio ha delle
aspettative ai dei sogni più o meno
grandi diversi ognuno ha i suoi c'è chi
sogna che diventa diventi come totti chi
sogna che possa avere una vita normale
ma non importa hai un figlio un qualcosa
di te che crescerà quindi è legittimo io
non entra nei sogni di chiodi
delle persone però in quel momento ti si
spezza qualcosa non ci vuoi credere dice
ma no la domanda che si fa la maggior
parte delle famiglie perché a me nasce
l'egoismo
questo è uno di quei quattro momenti
della vita sono quattro che sono
fondamentalmente la paura il gioco il
sesso e la disperazione in cui sia
maserati siamo noi stessi se una persona
generosa lo sei
sei una persona egoista lo dimostri li
hai coraggio però è un dramma
in quel momento questo muro da abbattere
solo tu non ti può aiutare nessuno devi
avere la consapevolezza che da questa
condizione non uscirai a è delicatissimo
ti arrivano veramente personaggi
bizzarri che ti portano delle cure che
non esistono rischi veramente tutto
rischia anche di andare in rovina
senti gente che ti parla di cure che la
scienza dopo di me parlare a una persona
che è titolata a parlare oggi con inter
così ti parlano dei buffoni finisci non
nulla questo muro purtroppo molta gente
non lo supera o lo fai finta che non
esista fai finta che non c'è un problema
o pensi che si risolverà da solo ma il
primo muro che devi abbattere ed è solo
tuo
questo muro porta al secondo questo più
che un muro è un perimetro è un
perimetro è la tua con force one
tu hai un lavoro hai la tua casa agli ai
tuoi amici hai la tua vita
tutto cambia tutto cambia cambia vi
regalo una rata di fatti miei io
lavoravo quando è nato mio figlio
lavorava in sudamerica il mio sogno era
portare la mia famiglia in sudamerica
con me il mio sogno era far crescere mio
figlio in un ambiente
da nomade quasi girare perché dal sud
america poi mi sarei mosso
ho dovuto ritornare in italia perché non
lo potevo spostare ma come me tanta
altra gente devi cambiare casa perché
magari ti serve un'altra casa se non ai
mezzi sono anche problemi immaginate una
casa magari dove avere una certo tipo
distanza gli amici ti cambiano ti
cambiano perché lì ti cambiano come fa
una persona un genitore ad avere l'amico
che magari chi piange addosso perché il
figlio non gioca titolare nella squadra
di calcio o la figlia nel balletto della
scuola e dietro ma ti gira le balle
fatemelo dire capisci che ci sono valori
diversi
quindi ti cambia questo mondi lavoro
devi essere più presente quindi devi
essere più vicino si sfasciano famiglie
la percentuale di divorzio nelle
famiglie con autismo è altissima e di
solito qua gloriosamente chi se ne va e
il padre è sempre un eroe
le vere eroine sulle madri quando io
sono qua a parlare magari mia moglie
segue mio film qui chi va in televisione
a raccontare i libri
dietro c'è una madre la madre sulle
rovine della disabilità benissimo questo
non è un muro la con forza cambia e
cambia è meglio perché trovi anche gente
più affine a te hai più legami chissà
allarga anche la mente e quindi questo
più che un muro è un cambiamento di
perimetro ma arriviamo
arriviamo poi al terzo muro questo ho
giurato sempre a mia moglie di andare
blando e il muro della pubblica
amministrazione diciamocelo devo stare
chiamò perché avrei degli aneddoti però
l'ho giurato anche perché credo che
siamo registrati a rischio di mi chiedo
scusa
la pubblica amministrazione bizzarra se
voi sentite ti dicono abbiamo fatto la
legge sull'autismo grandi una bomba
abbiamo fatto la legge sul dopo di noi
già un termine tristissimo dopo dire
durante dopo c'è proprio poi scopri che
parli con della gente che ricopre dei
ruoli che all 80 per cento parecchio
torna all 80 per cento non sa neanche di
cosa sta parlando
e ti racconta un sacco di fesserie
è un muro di cemento di cemento armato
questo non lo tiri giù neanche a morire
cosa devi fare allora stato non devi
fare come me di parlar male anzi io sono
contento mi trovo molto bene complimenti
fatti un applauso la pubblica
amministrazione numeri uno
bravi poi però io poi mi rivolgo a voi
giovani e diversamente giovani quasi
solo lo dico in inglese ice cream io a
scream ice cream io a scream non hai
screen gelato ice cream più a scream io
urlo il tuo grido io grido il tuo urlo è
l'unica strada per farsi ascoltare e per
cambiare prima nicolò rockol anche
riportate se non si lotta assieme la
singola voce non porta da nessuna parte
quindi per questo è importante
aggregarsi certo devi aver abbattuto gli
altri due muri cioè il primo soprattutto
perché se ti isoli sei finito la tua
voce rimane una voce ed è priva di
significato quindi questo murolo abbatti
solamente con una lotta arriva l'ultimo
muro che anche il tempo vola c'è
un'ansia e guardare qua il countdown
l'ultimo muro e il muro che io amo di
più è il muro della mano di te cosa sta
dicendo questo perché dico la mano li
faccio mi vorrei invitare a riflettere
su una cosa tutti noi da bambini siamo
stati accompagnati dai nostri genitori
mano nella mano la mano se io vi chiedo
quando è l'ultima volta che avete tenuto
per mano vostra mamma vostro papà o chi
altro voi non lo sapete ma io non so
nemmeno io cioè hugo 11 anni 14
magari no dieci non lo so quando è
l'ultima volta che mi ha fatto
attraversare la strada
qual è l'ultima volta che mi ha portato
per mano tra l'altro io non ho neanche
la sensazione della mano di mio padre di
mia madre o quella di mia madre perché
se essa è ribaltato tutto qualche anno
fa mia madre non c'è più era malata di
alzheimer
la portavo le tenevo la mano però è una
percezione diversa da bambino io non me
la ricordo e non mi ricordo quando ho
lasciato questa mano
bene per me il dramma è questa mano mio
figlio oggi ha 17 anni ma tante altre
famiglie hanno questa mano cresce cresce
da bambino cresce si alza diventano
uomini diventa la mano di un uomo non è
naturale tenere st mano non è naturale
questa mano non può crescere nella tua
perché ha avuto non ce la farai più ma
va bene la fondazione che io seguo cerca
di rompere questa maledetta equazione di
genitore figlio per sempre e come
abbiamo provato adesso dobbiamo andare
dei dei un contributo video che non è
passato
chiedo scusa però faceva vedere un po
tutto quello c'era un video è se lo
volete mettere proprio gli ultimi due
minuti che gira
noi abbiamo creato con la fondazione
questo nei miei ragazzi io non ho un
figlio o 1500 ragazzi in tutta italia
chiamò come se fossero tutti i miei
figli
abbiamo creato da un concetto di impresa
sociale cosa vuol dire per me impresa
sociale vuol dire creare delle attività
che generino ricavi da rinvestire che
però abbiano un principio quello di
potere includere lavorativamente questi
ragazzi questa bici che vedete un tandem
abbiamo brevettato questo non da solo
perché da solo non vai da nessuna parte
l'ho fatto con tantissima gente
l'abbiamo brevettato lo vendiamo in
tutto il mondo i ragazzi partecipano
all'assemblaggio come questo poi abbiamo
fatto lavori dei campi che ci portano
poco la terra non è che ti generi molti
ricavi abbiamo sviluppato concetti
legati all'alimentare ora abbiamo da
poco a poco tra due settimane inizieremo
a vendere una una nutella non posso
descrivere una crema di nocciola
particolare ci becchiamo anche
concorrente molto più buona però posso
garantire però non ditelo gravi
papa il papa le abbia regalato al papa
una tutto bianco e poi erano in due
quindi aver detto il tandem era perfetto
abbiamo però creato tante attività
abbiamo un pop up retail che è una
cinquecento la prima in europa dove
vendiamo gelato facciamo produrre i
nostri ragazzi del gelato delle delhi
dei biscotti od altro tutto questo li
tiene impegnati genera dei ricavi che
noi possiamo rinvestire e possiamo anche
sdoganarsi da dover anche la seconda
equazione disabile è stato lo stato
serve però oggi hanno compresso
guardate piani di zona di questa di
questa di questo territorio 19 centri
per gli adulti per i scusate per gli
anziani 0 disabili 0 per gli autistici
ma perché questo non dovrei dirlo c'è un
business c'è un business punto non c'è
una logica quindi ice cream io scream
bisogna lottare farsi sentire finire in
questi tavoli
concludo perché vedo che ormai manca
poco e avevo giurato di rispettare i 15
minuti
io la notte sinceramente faccio fatica
faccio fatica a dormire qualche volta
qualche volta dormo e lì magari il sogno
però realtà di notte io vivo tutti i
miei incubi
la mattina mi sveglio mi guardo allo
specchio e penso se vivo di incubi non
vado da nessuna parte
voglio cercare non solo di abbattere
questi benedetti muri o comunque di
creare delle porte ma oltre ai muri
credo che sia importante costruire dei
ponti è una frase detta e ridetta ma è
la verità
costruire un ponte vuol dire fare di
tutto per cercare di creare quel luogo
quelle condizioni
quel tempo quello spazio in cui questi
ragazzi tutti ragazzi possano avere
dignità inclusione e un futuro con e
senza genitori
grazie dell'attenzione
[Applauso]